the committee will be taking oral and
written evidence over the coming weeks
in order to inform its detailed report
on the framework
to be published ahead of the summer
recess
we begin today with four experts in the
field who are all known to us on the
committee we're joined by Jess sergeant
senior researcher at The Institute for
government
Dr Andrew McCormick former director
general of international relations for
the Northern Ireland executive office
Anton spezak senior fellow of the Tony
Blair Institute for Global chains change
and James Weber a partner of Sherman and
Sterling it's very good to see you all
again and we much look forward to
hearing your evidence
today's meeting is being broadcast and
the verbatim transcript will be taken
for subsequent publication which will be
sent to you all to check for accuracy
I would like to refer to the list of
members interests as published in on the
committee's website and perhaps I could
ask the the first question just to get
us going really which is if you could
give us your
overall assessment of the Windsor
framework and the extent to which it
resolves the problems that have Arisen
with the protocol and in doing so
perhaps you could also give give us your
views on whether there is a difference
of emphasis uh between the UK and the EU
Publications accompanying The Windsor
framework and if you do detect a
difference of emphasis does it matter
um so those are the questions which I
would like to go first
um Jess why don't we start with you yeah
great
um I think overall my assessment of the
winter framework agreement is that it's
a good pragmatic compromise solution
between the UK and the EU I think it
addresses a lot of the concerns that
have been raised by the business
community and the unionist community in
relation to the Northern Ireland
protocol uh importantly by reducing the
amount of paperwork and the extent of
checks and controls on Goods going
between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland now it doesn't remove them
entirely which was the UK government's
initial position but I think there's
some some really good working to
minimize them to the extent in which
they are necessary to protect the EU
single market so I think that's really
positive
um I think the storm won't break does
give the Northern Ireland and assembly
the power to raise concerns about new EU
regulation that could be implemented and
I think that's a a big Improvement for
the situation under the initial protocol
where all that law was just
automatically applied I think it's
important to compare the two there now
there are obviously areas where the UK
government in particular didn't get
everything that it asked for I think
around governance is is a big area there
um where they haven't necessarily
removed the role of the European court
of justice to the extent in which they
would have liked but I think the focus
on the sorts of issues that affect
people in Northern Ireland citizens and
consumers
is the right focus and you know other
things like pets and the movement of
pets which might seem like a trivial
issue that has a really important
um impact on on people who move
regularly between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland and so I think it's
it's important and good that they have
resolved those sort of everyday issues
in terms of the questions of the
difference of emphasis between the UK
and the EU I think we see this in a
couple of areas the first is on whether
some of the derogations that the EU has
provided
um on SPS in particular to allow Goods
that are produced in Great Britain and
sold in retail in Northern Ireland to
only have to comply with some parts of
EU law there are times where the UK
government calls that a dual regulatory
regime and the EU has been very clear
that it's not a dual regulatory regime
having said that when you look at the
substance of what they say that is
pretty much the same and similarly on
the storm on break I think the EU has
emphasized the sort of exceptional
nature of it that it is essentially an
emergency mechanism whereas I think the
UK government has not necessarily
presented it in in the same terms kind
of suggesting it's it's wider having
said that if you look at the detail of
both the UK and the EU documents the
actual conditions to which
um are the conditions that are applied
to the storm won't break are the same so
I think it's more in terms of
differences in terms of selling the deal
rather than in terms of the substance
and I think overall it's it's a good
Landing Zone
um after all of the sort of long
standing negotiations and challenges
that we've had in negotiating this
agreement
thank you very much for that pets are
never trivial
um I what I didn't do was ask each of
you to introduce yourself the first time
you speak and we know who you are uh
Jess started so thank you very much for
that perhaps I could turn to Andrew
McCormick next
um to ask us answer the same question
uh thank you chair it's a very good very
good to be here virtually and I I'm
using the freedom of of having retired
from the social service to speak more
freely than I could before I think it's
important in answering your question to
uh just pause for a moment on the
definition of the problems that we're
seeking to address or that the
government and the EU were seeking to
resolve I think Jess has correctly
focused uh on the pragmatic issues that
affect both businesses and citizens
which were proving very very difficult a
lot of them In fairness were known and
identified during the negotiations in
2020 but not resolved then uh I I just
would venture to say that I think there
are four points that have emerged in the
course of the last couple of years which
have become aspects of the definition of
the problem but which have quite weak
foundations
uh very controversially I would say that
the the active Union uh I don't think it
has that much relevance in the 21st
century I think the basis of the Union
of Northern Ireland and Great Britain is
very very well set in the Good Friday
agreement which had the support of a
majority of people uh in both parts of
Ireland a very very important success
and and we're marking its 25th
anniversary in contrast uh the active
Union was not supported by the people of
Ireland uh and doesn't really have a
legitimate Democratic basis uh even uh
if we look at a constitution
constitutionally at the time I know
that's controversial thing to say but
and I'll go further if need be but an
adventure to say that secondly
a new decade new approach did not
promise the restoration of Northern
Ireland's place in the UK internal
market and the reason that is very
simple that under the protocol and with
the nature of the the way in which the
Johnson government chose to settle
brexit there is no basis on which you
can have not around having identical
Provisions as the rest of the UK some
degree of difference is necessary if
uh it's accepted that there cannot be a
hard land border and that that's been
the the received wisdom uh from from
quite early after the referendum and
Remains the government's clear position
uh the logic the rest the rest is logic
in my in my humble opinion uh
third point is that
um being a rule taker is not necessarily
undemocratic uh Norway the eea countries
accept that they trade a significant
amount of sovereignty in exchange for
participation in the single market and
the position that the UK legitimately
adopted when it passed the withdrawal
agreement
in January 2020 was to apply that same
basic approach to Northern there are
important differences which I can go
into which are really quite important
but
um the principle uh is that it's a
legitimate Democratic choice
there's plenty of arguments against it
those are reasonable arguments to say
you shouldn't do it and the uh those
your favorite bracket will argue those
points very strongly but it's not
axiomatically wrong
finally then I I would say that the Good
Friday agreement
was not breached by the consent
Provisions made in relation to the
protocol
and that that was clearly the
government's position in 2019 that they
wouldn't have made the Declaration they
did without being sure their legal
ground that
the consent Provisions were legitimate
because uh international trade was and
has been an accepted matter since 1921
so the assembly hadn't had no role in
relation to manage International Trade
giving the assembly uniquely a voting
rule was an unusual measure and it was
legitimate as the government argued at
the time it was legitimate to do that by
simple majority and there is no
provision for across Community consent
in relation to anything that is of that
unique nature so I come I come to it
then really very simply
um if you accept the brexit trialama
in other words that if the land border
is open
uh the there has to have to be checked
somewhere
uh if against the the two two limbs of
the trilemma that the government has
chosen are uh to to withdraw from the
single Market Customs Union
and to have no land border then the the
remaining question is how to make sure
that the checks that are needed at
points of entry into Northern Ireland
are as under
undramatic as low-key as minimal as
possible and I I think that with the
work on the Windsor framework has
addressed that
primary column so long-winded answer but
but that's that was the problem that
could be addressed it was the only
problem that it was actually reasonable
to try to address and the Windsor
framework has made good progress in that
and then Arvin will come as you said to
the strong break which which has as Jess
said an important Dimension but that's
that was the test uh the The Windsor
framework is very very much better than
the protocol as applied and as agreed
originally
uh so that's my my summary well thank
you very much for that that's right
that's very helpful let's move to James
Webber uh next and then we'll come on to
Anton's Pizza James Webber
with you hello so um thank you very much
Jay so I'll do a little introduction
because I'm a competition and state aid
lawyer uh originally working in Brussels
now working in London uh my main
expertise in this area is in respect of
state aid and article 10 right um
although I have been quite strongly
involved in other areas I I will
um make that uh slight caveat at the
beginning
um in in terms of your question so uh
the
I take the view uh that the Windsor
framework is an improvement on what we
had before uh but that shouldn't
um take away from the fact that what we
had before was uh very poor indeed
uh I I take the view that the protocol
was was unnecessary you know as a way to
protect the single Market as a way to
solve the trailer as Mr McCormack just
described
and I think I've given evidence
previously to the committee on the
alternative solution that sort of I and
others were working on at the time of
the original uh withdrawal agreement
negotiations that that's
come and gone but at the time it was
called sort of mutual enforcement which
would have not placed the Border in the
RSC would have created the difference in
some way about the application of EU law
within Northern Ireland but would have
solved the problem
by a bilateral Arrangement between
Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland to enforce each other's trade
rules and collect the duties that we're
owing
um that period of History has has passed
so I've readily conceded that
um and we are with the protocols as as
it as it stands and the solution that it
presented so
um
I would say that you know the protocol
and the problems it presents uh
The Windsor framework ameliorates
some of them
but it has created fresh problems as
well too right and we'll come on to this
sort of particularly in terms of in
terms of state aid and you know article
10 which was the protocol provision and
his Liberation in the winter framework
about state aid you know that is
applying state aid rules to the entirety
of the UK
um remains an extremely unusual and
problematic provision which will have
um which has serious effects for the
UK's sovereignty and which was very
unwise to you know to continue in its
current form
um
the the other area is that because the
grace periods are ending at the same
time as the Windsor framework comes into
place you know some of the problems that
were in The Winds of the Windsor
framework is trying to fix weren't
actually fully realized because of the
application of the grace periods in this
in this period prior to now
and so I think when we come to look at
the red channels and the green channels
we will perhaps see some of those issues
come out and the solution that the
Windsor framework represents is indeed a
solution versus the protocol but may may
actually feel like a more intense level
of
IRC border versus the grace periods that
we have in place today
thank you uh thank you very much for
that Anton speedek uh over to you thank
you very much for the invitation today
I'm Anthony specific I'm senior fellow
at the Tony Blair Institute my view on
the Windsor framework is is that it is
the best practical answer to the Dilemma
that the objective of eliminating
the border on the island of Ireland in
the wake of brexit has created and that
this the decision to leave the single
markets create at the same time I
believe that
um it's a significantly improves
the status quo which is the full
application of the protocol
and at the same time IT addresses some
of the concerns over the Democratic
deficit which is related to the
automatic adoption of EU legislation and
the protocol that process has
significantly changed under the Windsor
agreement and and we can talk about the
detail of it but it does give the
elected nordinary representatives a far
greater say over the application of new
and changed EU legislation I think
that's a really important uh concession
actually that the European Union agrees
and it significantly moves from the
initial position which was that the the
mechanism for dynamic alignment is
sacred and uh there wasn't any initial
scope for changing that mechanism but
I'm a little bit concerned about is the
political dimension of
is the political dimension of this yes
agreement and that is the fact that
um
I think there is a significant risk that
the storm will break and we can get onto
it in a second in the detail
will create a potential for
um
uh future disputes essentially but also
that it will
um
it might in some circumstances encourage
hostility towards the EU and that it
might be tested in ways that is not
currently envisaged under the current a
ffair and I think that's where we get
into your second question which was
about uh the differences of emphasis
between the UK government and the
European commission I think there is a
big difference of emphasis actually in
description of the stone won't break
because if you look at the text that the
EU set out it talks very clearly about I
believe the most exceptional
circumstances and the use of that break
only as a matter of last result
the way that the UK government has tried
to portray the storm and break has been
quite different and has been as
essentially a mechanism for allowing
any group of mlas at least 30 of them
from at least two different political
parties uh to use that break so I think
there is a big difference of emphasis
potentially of understanding of force
that break is meant to do and that might
create its own difficulties but I'm sure
we'll get on to that in a second
well thank you very much for that I mean
we will indeed get onto that now uh
because uh it I think it's been clear to
all of us that the still not break is
one of the more important things to
discuss during this uh this session I
thought we might move on to it
um at this stage so Lord Lord Hearne
over to you thank you and and you're
welcome and it's good to have you with
us uh perhaps I could start with um
Jess's description to the store not
break as an emergency
um mechanism
and maybe you could elaborate on the
extent do you think that you think it
will ever be used and the implications
both legally and of its operation I'd
like them to follow up with a sort of
subsidiary question to you all once
we've addressed that on the general
principle about the the
um the scrutiny Resolute regulations
were passed today which seem to me to
have quite significant implications but
I'm not sure of your views on that but
if we could start with the break
generally yeah absolutely I mean so in
terms of characterizing it as
it is an emergency mechanism in in fact
I was quoting uh well technically the
the text of the of the deal and also uh
the EU as Anton said that was an element
that they were Keen to emphasize in
their own uh kind of documents where
that emergency and Last Resort comes
from is a reference to uh the
terms under which the petition of
concern can be used in the new decade
new approach deal and the UK government
have said that the use of the break
should be kind of equivalent to the use
of the petition of concern in that
circumstance so that's where that idea
comes from I think we haven't had much
chance to test out the petition of the
concern under the new Arrangements um
but I don't think that will as be as
strong a legal test as the conditions
around it being a significant change to
EU law and having significant impacts of
the on the community I think it's just
intended to signal that it shouldn't be
the first thing you reach for
essentially you need to kind of have
exhausted every other potential to find
a solution through the assembly and
through discussions with the UK and the
EU before that's used so I think yeah
the more important tests are those
around it being a significant change in
having significant implications in terms
of how often that that test is likely to
be made it's a little bit difficult to
predict because we don't have a clear
sense of of how EU law might change over
time and therefore how substantial those
amendments or updates to the existing
regulations might be I can foresee a
situation in which that might happen
um where the EU updates a piece of
legislation
um that is means that there is quite
significant Divergence between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland that isn't
captured under the sort of SPS
derogation that already exists under the
under the Windsor framework so if for
example
um the EU changed certain laws on kind
of uh product standards that that GB
hadn't then that could create a real
problem in importing certain products
from
um GB that would meet the test of that
being a significant change
um and having significant implications
on Northern Ireland because it would
affect consumers ability to be able to
purchase certain Goods from Great
Britain I think one of the questions is
whether changes in EU law will be
implemented through an update or an
amendment to an existing EU law which is
covered by the storm won't break or
whether the that will be a completely
new act which goes through a slightly
different procedure
um under that procedure uh the UK still
has the opportunity to to veto that in
in The Joint Committee
um and as part of the uh statutory
instrument that that was made that was
just that's just been voted on in the
House of Commons uh the UK government
has committed to provide an opportunity
for a cross-community vote on that and
saying it will only add that uh new EU
act in in the event that there is
cross-community support for that new act
so there's a kind of different type of
break actually there that's been
extended to new acts as well as
amendments or updates
um and on that cross community versus
the the 30
mlas
how does that in your View kind of play
else
I think it essentially creates a
two-stage process for the storm on break
the first stage is the 30 mlas
triggering it on an amendment or an
update and that leads to its automatic
suspension as long as the UK agrees that
the conditions for triggering it have
been met so you're in this position
where that you know law no longer
applies but then there's sort of a
second stage where the Joint Committee
are required to consider the amendment
update on which the break has been
pulled as if it were a completely new
law and at that stage there's another
opportunity for the assembly to have
input
um and that's when across Community
basis yes and an across Community basis
I think part of the reason that uh this
the process has been designed in this
way and having sort of several different
points at which both the assembly are
have the opportunity to express a view
but also where there's a sort of
mediation point for the UK in
determining where the conditions have
been met or coming to a decision with
the joint committee is to allow space
for this is to allow space to try and
find an alternative solution ultimately
we shouldn't see this procedure as you
know a cliff Edge that the first Port of
cool should be that that EU act um
doesn't ever reply because we know the
EU has the opportunity to make uh take
remedial measures and that can also just
create some challenges about Northern
Ireland's access to the EU single market
so I think we should conceive within
this process as lots of opportunities to
for the UK and EU to try and agree
another solution and that could be
through the EU providing derogations to
the ACT that it's proposing it could be
through the UK or um GB law changing in
order to prevent certain types of
Divergence so I think we should really
be seeing this as an opportunity for
Northern Ireland to raise concerns but
ultimately if they do if well or certain
communities Northern Ireland to raise
concerns if they do there is a
possibility that if a solution is not
found that that EU act will no longer
reply apply but our priorities should
actually be to try and find Solutions
before we get to that point and I think
that's the really under appreciated part
of the Stormont break is it creates a
very strong incentive for both the UK
and the EU to actually come to a mutual
agreement on this rather than get to
that Cliff Edge point where nobody
really knows exactly what what would
happen and Anton you were nodding at
that point I think James might have been
as well
at certain points probably yes I know I
broadly agree with Justice description I
think I mean I think just to take us a
little bit step back
um
it is a very significant Improvement on
the status quo which is that all EU
legislation that changes
legislation that is currently listed in
the annexes and that's about 300 plus
pieces of legislation
would be automatically updated without
any involvement of either elected
Northern Irish Representatives or UK
government
and that status quo essentially Falls
away now and there is now a very clay
process by which the European Union
would first notify the UK government and
the northern Irish assembly and that's
where we get into the Democratic
scrutiny legislation regulations excuse
me
um it would also notify the modernized
Assembly of any upcoming changes to the
in legislation as it applies to Northern
Ireland
and then there is a process which just
described where that storm won't break
could be used by a group of mlas under
certain conditions I would say that
those conditions are quite tightly
drafted so it's definitely not an
opportunity to uh to raise a petition of
concern for any change the
existing EU laws that apply to Northern
Ireland so there are those two
conditions that have to be met
simultaneously and one of them is that
essentially the nature of of replacement
e legislation has to have changed and
also it has to have demonstrable impact
on everyday life of communities in
Northern Ireland what I would say is
actually what has also changed and
that's just adding to Justice
description is the process for new ego
legislation coming into the protocol so
just to give you an example the European
Union is currently legislating for the
um so-called carbon border adjustment
mechanism which would impose certain
types for carbon heavy products like
steel or aluminum the EU initially
envisaged that that's practical effect
just if you could explain that in later
I'm sorry to interrupt your flow so for
example if if you are a GB steel
producer and you are exporting steel
into Northern Ireland in some
circumstances is there could be a GT
applied to that steel under this new
mechanism but this provision this
legislation has not been added yet to
the protocol and the only way for that
to be added onto the protocol would be
by a joint committee taking a mutual
decision
and at that point you would expect the
UK government to raise some questions
about this and say well this is all very
well but actually we would like to see
what is the actual impact of this
legislation on the businesses in
Northern Ireland and on the citizens
what the UK government has now proposed
in the statutory instrument is that any
decision that it would stake in the
future between committee when it
essentially decides on its position
would have to be preceded by a motion in
the northern Irish assembly and that
motion would have to be passed on a
cross community basis so that's a very
significant again very significant
change to the way that this process will
work in practice and it gives I believe
elected Northern Irish Representatives
far great to see over any future changes
to your law as we have previously seen
to that extent IT addresses the
Democratic deficit that lots of people
including it did happen to myself have
made concerned about I believe you dance
to a very large extent address that
concern and James you you were nodding
and disagreeing in both at the same time
I think I'd say something about the
state AIDS issue and all this yeah well
I think on the Stormont break
I think yeah sorry yeah I I would say
four points I think um the first is that
the stomach break doesn't apply to all
EU laws across the whole of the which of
the protocol it's limited to those set
out in headings one and seven and then
seven to 47 of nx2 and the eu's the laws
which Define the relief from duties on
personal possessions under Article Five
one so there are laws outside of the the
scope of the Proto scope of the Stormont
break which are going to be applying in
Northern Ireland for example vat the
Customs code the single electricity
Market state aid trade defense
so that's the first point
the second point which has been alluded
to by Justin Anton already is that the
ability to exercise the break is quite
strongly circumscribed by you know by
well tightly drafted I think is a good
phrase so the the law objected to must
significantly differ right from the
previous one and given that the you know
the scope of the EC or the the tfeu
um is uh the tfu itself right defines
the legal basis on which any any EU law
has to be founded what significantly
differ means compared to the legislation
that EU has on the books already is
going to be an open question the second
is the significant impact which is
specific to Everyday Life of communities
in Northern Ireland and which is liable
to persist so there's some Echo there
although it's more narrowly drawn than
the article 16 criteria that we've
discussed previously
the the determination of that threshold
is also subject to EU disputes the EU
has the right to raise a dispute in the
arbitration through the arbitration
mechanisms of the withdrawal agreement
as to the applications of those of those
criteria and that's an important
differentiator from the eea agreement
where the eea states are able to decide
for themselves whether or not those
criteria apply and then the remedy that
the EU has is suspension under the EA
agreement and that that actually is the
third point which is that the remedial
measures that the EU is empowered to
introduce in response to activation of
the storm on break are cast wider than
the suspension of the of the treaty so
in the the eea which is essentially the
model for this
concept that that permits suspension of
the benefits of the treaty whereas here
we have a different formulation which
refers to remedial measures now I think
Jess when
um you know you were addressing that
is quite a strong assumption that the EU
will act in good faith and that those
remedial measures will be in proportion
to the threat to the single Market
represented by the the law you're
attempting to disapply using the storm
won't break but that's essentially a
political sort of obligation the
remedial measures are
um for the EU to decide
and then the fourth point which is
building on something that Mr McCormack
commented upon is is whether or not it
does apply it does require the
cross-community consent Provisions under
under the new decade New Deal
because
um it's not obvious I don't think that's
clear
uh and I could be wrong but I don't
think that's clear and and insofar as
these Provisions are not
sort of GFA Provisions as it were
because they're they're an exception as
Mr McCormick yeah yeah then it's not
actually obvious that the cross
community consent provision would apply
to me but that would be my fourth point
and Andrew your take on this and I would
be particularly interested also
um to enter the question of the the
Democratic scrutiny committees come up
there's new proposal in the assembly
which seemed to me to be an advance on
where where we were before this but it
seems is it subordinate to them to the
Northern Ireland ministers I'm not clear
what the relationship is between given
your own Northern Ireland office
experience between the Northern Ireland
ministers is with the scrutiny committee
be able to interrogate Norman Northern
Ireland ministers or is it confined to
the storm and Arena
um so I I find that that was one of the
questions that struck me looking at that
this in the last few days was the the
absence of any mention of uh the
devolved ministers in the the scrutiny
process but I I do think the overall
it's a a helpful Dimension uh I think in
general terms my hope would be that it's
more difficult in theory than in
practice that in practice most of the
relevant amendments to EU law will be
not significant or not having a major
impact on uh everyday life or the all
the the the as others have said the
tests in the documentation are are high
and are challenging and while it's just
just said we need to avoid Cliff edges
there is a potential cleavage and this
links again to the the important points
James made about eea and where uh this
was one of the differences that struck
me strongly about the position Northern
Ireland would be in compared to the EA
countries but for them uh the choice is
relatively simple if something is so
significant for their economy that
they're prepared to put their
participation in a single Market at risk
then that's a a
it's just it's a comp it's a it's a a
judgment with high stakes uh and
potentially very significant
consequences but it's it's a it's a
choice for a sovereign state uh the
Dilemma that could emerge you know
thinking of trying to look at this at
worst case
is that there is a a changed EU law
which uh increases Divergence with the
rest of the UK very significantly and
that that's seems to me the the the why
the kind of reason there would be for
the criteria to be met uh and and
therefore you there's a the the choice
for North
foreigns don't have they have one big
partner Market not as in our case two so
that's an enormous difference uh and
then does bring in concepts of identity
and legitimacy that need to be thought
about very carefully
uh where I have a big concern uh and
James is correct to say that the
position on cost Community voting was
not clear in the original documentation
however looking at the the SI that has
just been passed by the commons
um the uh that does seem to introduce a
final uh applicability vote that would
be subject across Community consent no
again worst case if the consequence of
that vote is to
um
written allowance participation in this
in the EU single Market at risk then
world's most exciting economic zone
becomes an issue that could be being
overturned by a minority so I would
question whether a decision of that
substance
uh should be made on the basis of a
minority view in Northern Ireland which
is is which is the potential consequence
could you explain that so so if
something requires a cost if something
if the application of a law which is
essential in the eu's view to allow nor
Allen's continued participation in the
single Market
sorry I find it hard to imagine how that
could could arise but theoretically
that's why it's maybe more difficult in
theory than practice it theoretically it
could arise and in that circumstance if
the new law does not get across
Community Support it doesn't apply and
the EU EU invokes as James said remedial
measures which uh certainly could
intrude the kind of Provisions that are
in the EA eea agreements so that that's
a high risk and uh for me the the the
the the when I worked through in the
original work on the Good Friday
agreement running up to you know this
almost goes back to 1992 the principles
of how you take decisions the the
cross community votes were required to
change the status quo and and the
problem is the status quo's ambiguous in
this case because uh there you can look
at the status quo generally as in
Northern Ireland participate
participating in the EU single Market or
you can look at the States called
legalistically and narrowly and saying
it's this particular body of EU law
one of those is going to change uh for
me the the primary vote should be the
original decision on consent that was
provided for in the original protocol
where the assembly looks at the
principle of the application of the
protocol or the the defined articles of
the protocol and consensus or does not
consent and ideally would consent on
cross community basis but explicitly the
provision in October 2019 was that if
there was only a simple majority it
would stay in place for four years
so that's that's that's the general and
overarching position and if if the
majority of assembly want that to be
this tradition then it seems to be a bit
of a contradiction to then say that on
the basis of a particular amendment to
EU law the whole position might change
radically
that I I would just ask the question you
know is that Democratic uh they can see
whether I can understand entirely why
they're trying to do it and that the the
other other point is it it should work
if the tests are applied rigorously and
they and therefore a really big issue of
principal arises what I observe having
worked uh in the in it for uh not all
ministers in from 98 to O2 in the First
Assembly and then from all seven onwards
uh there is a tactical Ingenuity but as
gently as that as to how the rules can
be applied
uh that that's that's
characteristic of of our parties and
it's part of why we are where we are
today without a government uh and so so
creating uh tactical opportunities
um that's where again good faith will
the words as agreed with the EU be
applied in good face uh that there
there's that that's to me very very
important
um it would be better if we were in in
just I think if there was more time for
scrutiny again for scrutiny for an open
and transparent process that allows
businesses to express their views
pragmatically about what would be
implied By changes all these things come
into how the concepts will work out in
practice I I remain hopeful in principle
it's a it's a a better thing to have
than not to have but the detail is is
quite challenging
but I just conclude this by just asking
briefly for you Andrew but then the
others to say something about the
relationship between this new uh secure
Democratic security Committee of the
assembly the Northern Ireland ministers
and Northern sorry Northern Ireland
ministers Northern Ireland office
ministers ieuk ministers and mlas
I don't overstay my welcome but this is
quite an important issue it is an
important but if I could ask people to
be because we we otherwise we're out of
time to be quite brief and then we've
got Lord Thomas also on this question
but please
a very important question from Norte who
can go first just say believe that the
the
in a sense it again it matters less
in in practice in a theory because uh
the parties behave pretty coherently in
in the assembly so I I do find oh
there's no rules for ministers but if
the parties at work according to party
mandates then uh you can see a process
you would expect to see scrutiny it
would be better if that's open and
transparent but uh the the I think
the the logic of the process
and the degrees of scrutiny have have a
an internal coherence
briefly and then I I'm outside my
expertise I'm afraid and so on and then
Kate I would say yes
um I I would say it is an important
addition uh to the whole process because
what it does essentially it it
introduces syllable scrutiny that was
not available previously and that is
absolutely essential
um and it was one of my objections to
the original protocol which was that it
didn't did not provide sufficient
opportunities for
um on the one hand Northern Ireland
elected representatives to engage with
um upcoming legislations in the
pre-registered stages but also for the
UK government to be sufficiently
informed of what's coming up in the
pipeline I think both of these concerns
have now been broadly addressed and
actually if I can just draw the
attention of the community to one very
specific technical Point here there has
been a change to the rules of procedure
of the joint consultative working group
which is essentially a technical
committee underpinning uh the protocol
uh and the EU now has an obligation to
inform the UK government well in advance
of any potential changes and there is a
new kind of consult consultative
mechanism that would I think a
significantly help to ensure that
actually any changes abroad
to people's attention ball in advance so
I see there's an improvement but I I do
agree with Andre on the potential risks
here which which are that this this
mechanism can be I think uh subject to
political
um uh influence and it can be under
significant pressure if it's not used
correctly and as uh as
um as defined in the in the um in the
framework so I think I think there are
some risks but on the whole I think it
is a big Improvement
yeah just briefly in terms of there
fore UK ministers to appear before
devolved committees
um It's actually kind of Fairly common
but very inconsistently applied it kind
of depends where the ministers decide to
accept that invitation so I think one
thing that could be done is to ask UK
ministers for assurances that they will
appear between before this new committee
where there is an issue um within their
responsibility that they may be required
to take a decision but all your payments
they're definitely a precedent for that
and likewise this president
um
also appear before committees including
the Northern Ireland uh assembly
committees that has happened before and
so I think that would be a very valuable
uh part of the process thank you
hello Thomas
I've been looking at the EU side of it
and I I quote from that question and
answer explaining the uh Windsor
framework they say this the storm would
break
is a new emergency mechanism that will
allow the UK government at the request
of 30 members of the legislative
assembly Northern Ireland in the most
exceptional circumstances as a last
resort was sent out in a unilateral UK
declaration to stop the application of
amending or replacing provisions of EU
law that may have a significant and
lasting impact specific to the everyday
lives of communities in Northern Ireland
Lord Haynes first question was will it
ever be used to to um
to deal with that and and the problem
that I see and I like her comments on it
is that this is dealing with a a um uh
something that's come from Brussels
whether it's amending or original or
whatever
as a uh and and is complete and is then
stopped as opposed to more input in the
pre-legislative process
and surely that is where the emphasis
should have gone
um well Andrew let's have your view on
that yes no I I I I think I've said
even with the way things are
that's the right approach that entirely
the right approach it's what uh the EA
countries do and their access to working
groups and so on has been very important
for them in in the
ongoing evolution of the regulatory
regime in the Aki so so uh
for me
there will be a big need and this is
going to be a very major Demand on uh
not all civil service resources looking
ahead uh the the office that uh the nrcs
has in Brussels will need to be very
active uh need to be liaising
understanding what's coming coming
through because actually once as as I'm
sure many many committee members are
well aware once a proposal emerges it
will will be the result of probably
quite a lot of difficult compromise
among the 27 and so to to ask that then
at that stage to go back around the loop
and say we wanted to change for this
reason uh to get that agreed by all 27
or sufficient on if it's under qmv then
then there's a quite a challenge there
better to to be sufficiently well
informed
flag up at a very early stage to say if
you do that we have a problem that
doesn't create instant Solutions but it
seems to me to give a much better chance
of dealing with the issue in a pragmatic
way than than waiting uh so that the
levels of scrutiny after publication are
important but getting upstream and ahead
ahead of it is is to me vital
thank you I wonder if we could have
further comment yeah yeah I mean I would
absolutely um agree with Andrew I think
it's very important that these issues
are considered before the EU Act is
published in part because the time scale
actually for using the break is very
short
um the break has to be triggered the UK
has to give the EU with notification
that the break has been triggered within
two months of the EU act being published
so that suggests that actually a lot of
the heavy lifting needs to take place
before the actual publication of the ACT
um and I think that is foreseen to some
extent so I was just finding the part of
the statutory instrument
um that says that um the committee the
new committee that will be established
to scrutinize it can be given a
notification of EU acts that have been
proposed which suggests that there will
be some level of sort of pre-legitative
scrutiny here there's also provision in
the joint consultative working group
that the EU is required to share
information with the UK about upcoming
acts and then I presume that the UK is
intended to notify the committee now
that hasn't really been happening very
well at the moment in part because of
the the poor relationship it's between
the UK and the EU but also because I
think there's not a really strong
incentive to do it I think both the UK
and the EU can kind of carry on with
their own regulatory uh proposals
without really thinking about Northern
Ireland as as I said earlier I think
actually one of the really positive
consequences of the break is it creates
so what if they are if they don't you
know share information at an early stage
and hold these discussions and consider
Northern Ireland in developing EU
proposals then they run the risk that
later on the break might be triggered so
I think the break creates an incentive
for that engagement at an earlier Point
well there doesn't appear to be a place
for for Northern Ireland elected
representatives
um or no explicit place for for Northern
Ireland civil servants in the
pre-legislative
consideration
I would probably push back slightly on
this point because I think as part of
the changes to the agents um
consultative working group there is now
an obligation on the EU to uh to inform
the UK government of any upcoming
changes and that's not as just explained
not just after an act has been published
in the journal but also in the in in the
in in the in the stages when the ACT is
being passed that's my interpretation
and reading of that provision
so I would just probably add that in
practice this all depends on how good
are the working relationships between
officials in the European commission and
the in the EU system and the UK
government including in the northern
Irish executive and if those
relationships are strong and productive
then I think quite a lot of
heavy lifting will be done in that early
stage through the technical committee
both demoted officials included
I'm it's not clear to me but I I
wouldn't see any
strong reason why those officials should
not be included as part of that process
because the definition is very broad
yeah I understand that the UK government
has committed to including either
Northern Ireland politicians or
officials depending on who's appearing
in its delegations in meetings of the
joint committee and subsequent
structures
yeah that's at the Joint Committee level
there are several kind of structures
under it some of which are just attended
by officials and again the UK government
has uh committed that the appropriate
level essentially would attend as part
of the delegation I think we're going to
have to move on because we're getting a
long way to go are there any other other
points there or should we move on to
burn as Richie and thank you Lord chair
and you're all very welcome
and in the background briefing and to
the political declaration by the
European commission and the UK
government it states that the framework
reflects the full commitment of both to
protect the Good Friday agreement of the
10th of April 1998 and its subsequent
implementation agreements and
Arrangements so in that respect how
would you assess the Windsor framework
against the UK and the eu's joint
commitment to protect the Belfast Good
Friday agreement including its
subsequent
um implementation and agreements and
Arrangements in all its dimensions and
strands and by that I mean strand one
strand two and strand three and I
apologize I forgot to declare an
interest I'm a member of the board of
cooperation Ireland and of course I'm a
former member of the assembly and a
minister of the Northern Ireland
executive several years ago so I'll
start with Jess
absolutely
um I think the agreement does go a long
way to trying to protect those three
strands I mean firstly the purpose of it
is to try and restore the domestic
institutions which are obviously a very
important element
um of this
um and in doing so trying to uh address
some of the concerns that have been
created about that um with the kind of
nigb relationship which is itself is not
a specific strand but it's also an
important Dimension here
um it's maintained uh north-south
cooperation including uh in maintaining
frictionless action between the two I
think one thing that's important to
emphasize is that obviously uh the
north-south institutions including the
north south ministerial Council
um have been in abeyance longer than the
S um longer than the assembly in the
executive actually in part a protest of
the protocol so I hope if we're in a
situation in which the assembly is
restored that we will also restore those
north-south institutions and I know
there's been some legal challenge to
that particular action and so I hope
that be part of any progress if we do
see it but I think actually also one of
the things that the agreement does very
well is
um re-establish the um East-West
Dimension and improve relationships
between the UK government and the Irish
government which have really suffered as
a consequence of brexit in this ongoing
disagreement and I think it's actually
been uh very heartening the extent to
which those have seemed to have repaired
um quite quickly after this this new
agreement so
um although there are obviously ongoing
problems I think uh the Good Friday
agreement requires ongoing work and
ongoing support in order to continue the
functioning of all those strands but I
think there are elements of this
agreement that speak to
um all three of them Anton
I would perhaps just add one point to
that description by address and that is
I think that the EU in the moving uh in
its position and in showing more
flexibility and how it applies ELO
it now applies ELO essentially by
exempting Northern Ireland from aspects
of its own legislation which is quite an
important I think conception by the
European Union I think it reflects that
special status of Northern Ireland and
the special conditions that the Good
Friday Agreements are established so I
think that is now more reflective in the
European Union's position and in in its
in its own legislation and how it treats
Northern Ireland
I think the other aspect that I would
add would be in relation to
um articles 6.2 of the protocol and
that's a little close which says that it
is really important to ensure in
Northern Ireland's place within the
United Kingdom and there has been
actually an amendment through the
Windsor framework to that particular
clause and the two sites of committed to
giving each other more flexibility to
how that provision is implemented which
again I think speaks to that East-West
Dimension and it's strengthening through
this Arrangement thank you James so my
comment would be that the Northern
Ireland protocol you know was about
protecting the EU single market right
and the Windsor framework is also about
protecting the single Market that that's
its purpose
um The Good Friday agreement had nothing
to say about trading Goods which is what
the Northern Ireland protocol are now
the Windsor framework are about so
the it's not surprising I think that the
the there's a level of dissonance
between the two documents right the
Windsor framework has made some progress
towards recognizing that the Good Friday
agreement but it still doesn't use the
institutional architecture or even
really refer to the institutional
architecture The Good Friday agreement
in terms of the British Irish Council
the obligations on the Irish government
and the British government to reach
bilateral agreement on EU issues you
know which is part of the
um of the Good Friday agreement that's
also not present so I think it's it's
probably a step forward the EU seems to
be increasing its understanding of some
of the issues and complications but it's
ultimately
not really about uh uh the Good Friday
agreement it's about protecting the eu's
single Market in my view
just a supplementary to that would you
accept the fact that the Good Friday
agreement was made and people were very
conscious then of our common membership
of the European Union in fact you could
say that there were models used in the
European Union that translated in terms
of bringing people together or sharing
and Reconciliation so therefore some
would suggest and would you agree with
that
to an extent that's definitely true
right the Good Friday agreement didn't
need provisions on trading Goods because
we're obviously both members of the
single market so so a level at one level
that's absolutely right at another level
The Good Friday agreement
refers by you know to bilateral you know
UK Republic of Ireland and the
institutions of Northern Ireland and
doesn't make any reference to
institutions of the European Union
whereas the north good whereas the
northern protocol in Windsor framework
is all about the institutions of the of
the European Union and the kind of
interlocutor is the European commission
and not the Irish government and so in
that that's
what I mean that's a fundamental
difference but uh between the two
agreements I think thank you Andrew
Mr yes the I'll go back to the beginning
really is that as as others said
trade issues were not foreseen as an
issue in in 1998 uh the uh Assumption of
ongoing EU membership was was maybe not
explicit but it was just not taken for
granted maybe and my comment would be
that there is no outcome of brexit that
doesn't disturb the delicate balance
that's a phrase that's been used about
it there's the the the delicate balance
of the agreement is Disturbed in some
way I think it's also a matter of fact
that the threat of a hard land border
had a head start of at least a year
conceptually in the in the rhetoric of
the debate before anybody really
realized and focused on the fact that
there was potential risk of dislocation
between not around and the rest of the
UK so I I can certainly we argued that
if you only looked at the issue in
Constitution additional terms than the
trelemma would be resolved by a hard
land border that that there's a strong
constitutional Arguments for that and
the there are land borders elsewhere
across the one between Croatia and
Bosnia uh last year through a curve
Loris
um but if you add into the into the mix
both the pragmatic impact and the
dislocation of society the case for
managing the checks in a minimalist way
through the ports of Entry is that the
the case is there it is the the it
becomes uh it probably should have been
approached as an open political judgment
in saying we now have a problem what's
the best what's the most pragmatic
solution to it rather than uh getting
into I'm trying to rewrite history here
and it's not really not helpful but we
we've been on a long journey
getting it back to the the what I would
quote from article one five of the
agreement itself which says we we the
participants pledge we will in good
faith work to ensure success of the
arrangement established uh the
institutions as you said uh are are
um interdependent uh the the strands are
interdependent uh there is an issue uh
arising from brexit generation to strand
too because north-south Corporation was
affected and and uh there was a
perceived threat there is also a very
significant issue of course though there
was no discussion in the in the in 1988
on the relationship between gbn and I
want but if if the if the fact was no
Long Island was remaining part of the UK
uh the the what how that operated
remained as before from uh principles
established in 1921 and in in the
Constitution back in the 1970s rather
than being reinvented so the the pars
given to the assembly where where the
issue in strand one was was high those
would be exercised and how power sharing
would work so things these are
unforeseen problems that they to me they
the the better way would have been to to
look at them in an open way to say well
well we've got a set of problems here uh
what's the what's going to be helpful
what's going to
provide a pragmatic compromise that that
is as close as possible to the spirit of
the agreement
but get applying it's attempting to
apply its letter when it didn't say that
say anything about these issues is
really very difficult thank you very
much thank you thank you very much um
Mariners alone well thank you Lord
um I'd like to ask you for your
assessment of the Windsor Frameworks
Provisions in relation to customs
procedures and the movement of goods
between GBA and Northern Ireland
including the arrangements for green and
red channels and an enhanced trusted
Trader scheme handling of tariff raise
rate quotas and the system of commercial
data sharing and then finally how would
you can assess the particular
arrangements for the agri-food retail
trade into Northern Ireland and perhaps
let's start with with James if I may
yeah sure so I I've met my comments
quite brief on this so conceptually the
red lane is the default so you know the
red lane is what applies And Then There
are a set of exemptions where you can
use the Green Lane and the the Green
Lane concept is that
they would permit import from GB to
Northern Ireland
um where processing in Northern Ireland
is for the purpose of sale a limited
number of things so certainly better
than we had before but a limit a number
of things so sale of future and consumer
so that fixes the m s the sausage
problem
the incorporation of processed Goods
into a permanent structure the provision
of recipient of health care or care
services by the Importer of subsequent
entity not-for-profit activities by an
importer and final use of animal feed so
that there is also a safe harbor for
smes so those
um with an annual turnover of less than
two uh two million pounds so the that's
the the Green Lane operates by way of
exception if you can qualify under any
of those into any of those provisions
and it removes the need for checks
um one of the difficulties with the with
with the red lane
is that everything else then comes in
under the red lane and you've got
items uh you know where tariff
obligations May apply
because notwithstanding the TCA you
still have to comply with the rules of
origin
requirements of the TCA in order to
benefit from the Tariff treatment and so
you've got sort of tariff potential
barriers or at least showing showing
um compliance with with rules of origin
which makes importation from GB into ni
difficult if you're using the red lane
um
the
uh there is also sort of
the remaining that the structural
problem the original structural problem
created by the design in article five of
the protocol which is that everything is
caught by the EU rules and you know
because everything is at risk of import
subsequent importation to the EU unless
it's decided not to be that that
structure has been has been retained
right so essentially the Green Lane
represents a further definition of
things which are not quote at risk of
further importation into the EU but the
the at-risk concept is still something
that the EU sort of controls so you know
the better approach would have been to
agree
um
uh to switch that right where the where
the things which were at risk were were
truly at risk right based on the
evidence of actual trade flows across
the north-south border either statically
looking back or dynamically based on the
market surveillance of you know trade
surges and such like and using that to
inform uh what the concept of at-risk
means rather than essentially
the Green Lane operating by exception to
the default regime okay
that was your original Concept in a way
wasn't it that that
um
the way of enforcing the differences
would be drastic Draconian penalties for
people who cross the border
uh well it it would involve the use of
the criminal law or to enforce the rules
of the other party yeah so that
exporting a product that did not comply
or you know had not paid the duties
would be a criminal offense in the
exporting jurisdiction that was the
fundamental idea behind Mutual
enforcement but but this my commentary
on this is is based on the balance of
where does the exception lie so the
Green Lane is an exception to the red
Lane right and that means that the
exception is drawn reasonably tightly
and you can have lots of examples where
you're outside of the exception where
the EU gets to continue to decide what
is at risk and that in my view is an
excessive
you know quite fundamentally excessive
um if we look at the I think we have to
we're going to have to move on because
we're getting terribly late yeah
yeah absolutely um I'm not a trade at
all Customs expert so I'll be fairly
brief on this one uh but I think uh the
point side raise were around sort of
implementation and assuming that um
ensuring that the scheme Works in
practice I think it's good that it
builds on existing schemes like the UK
Trader scheme that we've already had
experience of operating I think already
we identified the UK and the EU
identified some problems with that that
have been remedied through this solution
but I think that suggests that there
might need to be a little bit more rigor
room for four further adjustments as
this scheme kind of beds in and is
actually
um being implemented I think another
point I would make is around UK
administrative capacity and because in
some cases uh where there's less burden
on the traders to provide information
around Customs some of that burden falls
on the UK government and the trader
support service so ensuring that that
maintains a free service that Traders
can use I think is is really important
and there should be assurances on that
and also the need to maintain retain
trust I think the data sharing agreement
between the UK and the EU and the new
database the Buddhist bespoke database
that the UK government has built has
been really important in being able to
reach this agreement so continue data
sharing and building of trust is really
important there
um just just to quickly touch upon the
question around the agri-food retail
trade scheme this was actually one of
the areas where I was surprised that the
the EU had actually moved this far we'd
heard for a long time that this was not
something they were going to budge on
and I think what we've landed on is
actually a really pragmatic solution
where where there is actual risk of
diseases spreading across borders that
those rules had to be complied with but
other things around consumer protection
um if the products are coming from GB
don't need to comply with those
requirements that solves a real actual
problem that we could be facing for
example
um in the coming years when the when the
UK changes its definitions of Gene
editing you know that was that was a
problem that could have prevented Goods
going from Northern Ireland that's now
been solved and I think that's a really
positive uh development that will
maintain a supermarket Supply chains
which was one of the primary concerns
about the application of the protocol
thank you very much Antoine I would say
that quite a lot will change in practice
because we have to remember what is the
status quo at the moment which is oh
would what would it be a status quo if
the protocol had been fully implemented
and that would have been uh GB
businesses moving any Goods into
Northern Ireland whether they're
intended for the final consumer in
Northern Ireland or elsewhere facing the
exactly same Regulatory and Customs
burden and we have now moved completely
from that from that from that default
and now there is a really important
distinction here which is based on the
final destination of goods and to the
extent that the goods are destined for
Northern Ireland and for the final
consumer in Northern Ireland essentially
for all the purposes of movement of
those goods from GB to ni they will be
treated very very differently and the
burden on businesses will be very very
heavily reduced but not completely
eliminated it's it's very important to
say but although you previously had to
do as a business fill out
24 Customs fields on a piece of paper
you will not have to feel a single one
now because it will be a responsibility
of hmrc to ensure that those goods are
properly uh
uh you it will be still responsible to
pre-declare the goods that we are moving
but it will be the responsibility of
hmrc to then fill out that effectively
that Customs form for you so that will
significantly change practically for
businesses the other point I would make
is that the scope of The Trusted Trader
scheme will also be expanded and I think
it's really really important because
previously for your business which was
moving goods from GB to ni it had to
have for example physical premises in
Northern Ireland to be able to qualify
for that scheme that's no longer going
to be the case so effectively more or
less any GB based business will be able
to qualify for the scheme there will be
some initial requirements to be able to
do that but those requirements will
ultimately outweigh any kind of benefits
from uh from the from participating in
the scheme so I do think this will make
a real difference and I I'm actually
really glad to see that the EU has been
able to to take a more proportionate
approach and more risk-based approach to
to any kind of controls and and
requirements that are necessary for
movement of goods because I do think
it's the right approach to be able to
treating the good space and Final
Destination
okay thank you very much Andrew would
you like to so several quick points I I
think the Arkham Knight on the General
application of the Green Lane red lane
idea is uh much much better than when I
originally proposed it in March of 2018
uh it's moved on at a much more
pragmatic way I I think on I would look
at it as glass half half full or
something which which with experience
trust
the opportunities for the concerns that
James has raised in particular to to
diminish and for the more things to
normally be accepted in the Greenland as
a matter of practice I think it's not
that surprising if you look at it
tactically that the uh
the default is the safer option given
that the UK
agreed definitions of at-risk and an
approach to agri-food in December 2020
said they were they were happy with them
at that time and within eight weeks were
desperately unhappy with them and that
was a major uh u-turn
by the UK government
at that time uh not based on the actual
experience but given that the grace
periods had applied but um what I would
regard as tactical opportunity so so
trust was low to achieve this and build
trust and I think part of what the the
really really important benefits of the
agreement that's been reached is of
massive Improvement uh and trust and for
that to build and grow is important I
was also like just surprised uh I I did
not include agri-food Goods at all in my
original Green Lane Redland proposals in
March of 18 and picking up something
James said earlier uh The Advocates of
alternative Arrangements in the Auto
World 2020
they acknowledged there was no uh I
would put it this way that that you
can't stop a pathogen with a camera and
the purpose of the spls rules is to stop
disease and so when
prime minister Johnson
proposed the full application of EU law
and their and that all agri-food Goods
would come into Northern Ireland through
water control posts in his paper of
October 2019. that was a very black and
white
expression but it was uh you know safe
and logical if you if if the if the
primary seat was to protect as he put it
in that paper to protect the island of
Ireland as a single epidemiological zone
uh so we've moved on a long way from
that and the the ability of the EU to
find a different way to manage those
risks is it really solves an immense
problem with the agri-food but we knew
uh as snowing on civil service through
2020 was was a really difficult thing
so I I think there's this is much much
better than it might have been yes uh
there are uh continuing difficulties
it's been I think oversold as in too
simplistic a way but I looked at in
detail it stands as as better than
anything else I've ever seen in in this
context
thank you thank you thank you thank you
Lord Dodds
um online Nigel thank you fair and um
I just wanted to come on to the issues
then of
stadia and v80 in exercise so the
government the
British government proposed on stage the
stated it should be taken over the
protocol altogether there was no need
given the arrangements from the training
cooperation agreement
so now I ended up a situation where
there's no change in relation to the
legal position on Stadium but there's
been a declaration on the application of
article 10 one so I just want to get
reviews on on what the status of that
declaration is and what what change if
any there is in in the legal position
regarding stereo rules for Northern
Ireland secondly on vat and excise just
to comments on how how you see any
changes there in terms of how they apply
to Northern Ireland but also this UK EU
cooperation mechanism which seems to
give
a greater role to the EU in relation to
the wider issue of Taxation in the UK as
a whole sort of interested in your
comments and that
um maybe start with James and share
quite an expert on steady and stuff yeah
certainly not an Express on vat so I'll
uh limit my remarks to stay tuned so
um you're right at Lord Dodds that the
provisions and do not change
um so there's no change to the
provisions of article 10
um and what that means is that the EU
state aid rules apply not just in
Northern Ireland but to the UK as a
whole like very important distinction
between article 10 and many of the other
provisions of the of the protocol is
that
um the formula is that it applies to the
relevant rule applies to the UK in
respect of Northern Ireland is how is
how it's typically framed that's not
used in respect to article 10 the EU
statade rules apply to the whole of the
UK right
um
and so with article 10 in place we now
have two competing subsidy regimes one
pile on top of the other one is our
domestic subsidy Control Act 2022 which
we introduced and that reflects the
obligations of the UK under the trade
and cooperation agreement and then on
top of that right except of other
Windsor framework we have the EU state
aid rules which as I said apply to the
whole of the UK
so the only
so the
um what the protocol did and what the
winter framework
does also is talk about the
circumstances in which the state aid
rules you know apply to the whole of the
UK so they apply to the whole of the UK
but there is a jurisdictional sort of
test that they only apply to a whole of
the UK in certain circumstances and
under the uh protocol those
circumstances were that the relevant Aid
measure had to affect that trade covered
by the protocol uh essentially north
south trade in Goods or or electricity
um the new formulation
which is not a change to protocol itself
but is a joint declaration and I think
probably amounts the same thing is that
there has to be a genuine and direct
link to the to the north to Northern
Ireland uh and that that has to be
material and not merely hypothetical and
that sales in Northern Ireland of
themselves are insufficient and there
has to be an economic effect of the aid
right
um in Northern Ireland so we've
essentially got a group of words which
have been a piled on top of each other
to say when do we have a situation of
the EU state aid rules applying to a GB
or UK Aid measure they have to be they
have to have that sort of strong
connection to Northern Ireland
and that's an improvement on what we had
before certainly
where but I think it creates a number of
problems the first problem which is very
underestimated is that
the UK is competing increasingly an
environment for international mobile
investment
the UK uniquely in the world has got two
subsidy control regimes right the EU
rules and the UK has its own rules and
under the UK rules you can deliver
certainty and under the EU rules you can
deliver certainty but that requires you
to notify the European commission and so
the difficulty will come when you have a
project in the UK say a battery Factory
in Sunderland
that receives Aid does that Engage The
Northern Ireland protocol does selling
the cars in Northern Ireland that come
from that battery Factory is that a
sufficient link to Northern Ireland to
engage the protocol
so beneficiary sales on their own might
not be enough but what about
that plus a subsidiary that plus a
branch or a dealership Network
there has to be an economic effect in
Northern Ireland what sort of economic
effects
what's that you know is to be litigated
and so you've got a problem with a
battery Factory let's say in Sunderland
the UK government issues it with a
subsidy it approves it under the UK's
own substitute Control Act and then you
have a latent risk lurking under the
surface did you or did you not infringe
the Northern Ireland protocol Windsor
framework by not also notifying it to
the European commission and the problem
is unless you notify it right
and if you will not you won't know right
and the limitation period for that
answer is 10 years so you're asking an
investor to take that risk essentially
for a 10-year period that their
subsidies are not in are potentially
challengable
if you solve it by notifying the
European Commission
you will give the European commission
and I having worked in this area for 20
years have a certain degree of cynicism
right you will give the European
commission the decision
about what amounts to a sufficient and
material connection to Northern Ireland
right they will decide that point and
the only Court you can appeal that point
to is the European court of justice
which I can confidently predict will
give you an expansive interpretation of
that right so
the the decision or the Omission to
leave the the state aid the EU state aid
rules applying on top of the subject
Control Act
and bear in mind the subsidy Control Act
is that reflects the arrangements of the
TCA which the EU has accepted are
sufficient to generate a Level Playing
Field leaving the two on top of each
other uh is a very serious mistake
that's very much James um
you know maybe on the v18 aspect of it
I mean just the first thing on this on
state aid I would I would say I was
surprised that the article 10 was not
amended because I thought I understood
why article 10 was drafted in the
initial context which was the UK did not
at that time have a domestic subsidy
control regime that was 2019 but the
circumstances have changed and we do
have quite a robust subsidy control
regime after uh after brexit and there
is a provision within the withdrawal
treaty with respect to all the Joint
Committee can do article 164 which can
address circumstances not for a scene at
the time of signing the treaty so I had
expected that the negotiators would have
used that provision to amend that
article for the reasons mostly that
James outlined because it does
potentially create difficulties around
certainty and stability for businesses
and investors
um but I I do think that this will
ultimately be settled in courts because
of the ambiguity that uh this this
provision creates
uh on on VHC I would say that the
EU v80 perfume still applies as a
default to Northern Ireland but there is
a set of quite Broad and I would say
ambitious exemptions from that EU bat
regime and there is now more flexibility
to set uh bat rates for Northern Ireland
in a way that that are more consistent
with bet rates in the breast of the UK
and there are certain
um certain ways of doing that including
quite a wide exemptions for smes
for alcohol duties and so on so there is
a degree of flexibility that wasn't
there previously in the original
protocol but the evat perfume still
applies as default
okay yeah
um so I think the original protocol did
actually give quite a lot of flexibility
on vat it just wasn't used
um would be kind of my interpretation in
that the joint committee is empowered to
adopt measures in relation to bat where
uh the application of the EU regime
could have implications for the UK
internal market and we've seen that with
the exemptions for example for example
on um uh some of the kind of
environmental policies and also in
alcohol duties and things like that so I
don't think we actually needed the
Windsor framework in order to get those
exemptions they could have happened at
any point but obviously the politics
prevented
um that happening so I think this is
more the the doing committee using
powers that existing under the protocol
rather than necessarily creating a whole
new set of Arrangements although as as
Anton said there were the kind of
blanket exemptions for smes and also
this enhanced coordination mechanism I
think empower to try and facilitate uh
future exemptions where they might be
necessary so
um what we've got is a case-by-case
Approach at the moment and I think one
thing we need to make sure is that where
there are legitimate cases going forward
that we do see further exemptions and
there are those discussions taking place
um because as Anton says the default is
that the evat regime applies
thank you Jess Andre
I think later out to the technical
points all I would say very briefly is
is that I could understand the EU being
costly these things because they've been
clear all the way through that that
they've not been indicted that the
protocol was giving Northern Ireland uh
a unique set of economic advantages in
terms of the the general issue of dual
Market access and therefore to be
cautious about issues of Level Playing
Field and and competition has a
rationality uh a a defer to the what the
the technical points that other made on
on how that works out uh that's only a
broad uh broad tactical point
it's very much indeed like you know our
chair thank you thank you logos I want
to to move on to talk about
um regulatory Divergence
um uh Lord MP over to you
your beauty
no I think I'm off okay you're off now
you're off now
um
could I ask the
what is the significance of the Windsor
framework for regularly Divergence both
East-West and north south to what extent
will the Windsor framework protect both
Northern Ireland's Integra placed in the
united King's internal market and its
unique access to the EU single market
and Divergence is something I've been
concerned about and the committee's
taking very seriously over the last year
or so so I've been very interested in
the witnesses responsive to a police and
start with Jess
great thank you um I've also been very
interested in Divergence not just
between uh GB and ni but within uh the
UK internal market in terms of Scotland
and Wales as well so this is something
I've been thinking a lot about
um and to that extent I think what the
winter framework do does is basically
um allows more gbni Divergent to be
tolerated in the areas in which the UK
is most likely to diverge um and here
I'm preferring to specifically some of
the SPs
um regulations
um I think that exemption for retail
Goods
um to not have to comply with EU law in
areas that aren't related to Animal
Health
um is a really useful development in
order to allow
um GB or in this case specifically
England to implement some of its plans
for example for Gene editing
um to prevent challenges that might
arise for example of changes to EU law
or on things like labeling I think
actually the Windsor framework helps
resolve a lot of those problems and
allows the UK or England more
specifically to diverge in those areas
without it immediately meaning that it's
much more difficult to sell Goods to
Northern Ireland so I think that's a
really positive development obviously
that exemption doesn't cover all
regulatory areas and I know one of the
concerns raised earlier in the debate on
the statutory instrument was around
manufactured goods the fact that they
will still need to comply with EU law I
think as the command paper itself points
out actually in areas like product
standards a lot of those regulations are
informed by International standards and
therefore we wouldn't actually expect a
huge amount of Divergence in those areas
um anyway so I think that's less a
problem I think this particular
exemption for SPS is particularly
important
um in terms of how much the Windsor
framework will protect the internal
Market I think one of the challenges
here is that the alternate eternal know
the UK internal Market is still a very
um still a very new and contested
concept
um particularly around between Scotland
Wales the UK government Northern Ireland
um so too it's a bit difficult to test
what that exactly that means because I
think there is some extent in which
particularly the Scottish and Welsh
governments might like the opportunity
to have
um sort of more regulatory barriers in
some way and to some extent are a little
bit jealous of the fact that Northern
Ireland can prevent the entry of certain
Goods if they don't meet EU standards in
a way that they can't because they argue
that it could undermine their own kind
of regulatory standards so it's quite
difficult to judge exactly whether that
test has been has been met but certainly
I think these Arrangements permit more
Divergence whether that will be
desirable to all businesses at all
points I think is a slightly different
question
thank you Anton
thank you very much for that question I
think it's a fascinating issue which I
actually arises in this context and what
I would say is there is one problem that
I can envisage and that is a problem of
competition actually in this context if
you imagine a scenario and just to take
just as example a step further around
Gene editing if GB decides to
um change its gene editing standards as
the government intends to do but the EU
would not
reciprocate which obviously it has its
own processes for deciding what it does
do
and then it will essentially end up with
GB producers being able to lawfully
Place their products which are of a
slightly different standard on the
Northern Irish Market while Northern
Irish producers we still have to produce
the same products but down to different
standards and that standard maybe higher
or lower depending on you know what what
exactly is the nature of that legal
change but it might actually create I in
my view problems around competition
within the northern Irish markets on its
own and it raises questions of consumer
choice and and so on I'm not a a
consumer protection expert but it seems
to me like potentially quite an
important
issue which has been slightly
underlooked in this whole context and I
think at the end of the day it will all
really depend on how well the new
domestic internal Market surveillance
regime Works in practice there is a
whole new office for internal market and
I'm presuming that office is one of its
responsibilities will monitor some of
those questions and how they how they
operate in practice but I think it will
be quite quite a tricky job actually to
do it well I think the other point I
would make in this context of regulatory
Divergence is the
uh the risk that's the retained ELO Bill
braces in the context of the benzo
framework and I actually I'm off with
you that the retained ELO bill is
fundamentally incompatible as currently
drafted
with Windsor framework and it does
require substantive amendments if it if
it is to be made compatible
and and there are three very specific
reasons for that one of them is uh the
fact that a lot of this e-legislation
that would would be subject to the
sunset Clause is essentially within the
scope of the amended protocol as it
stands right now
even after the the latest changes the
other problem which is I think much much
greater than that is the fact that
um the withdrawal treaty
um requires the UK governments to
produce the same legal effects for any
new legislation within the protocol as
as for any member states essentially and
again uh the retain the low bill would
fundamentally change the nature of how
essentially retained E Law is treated
within the UK legal order which I
believe is incompatible with that
commitment it's article for the
withdrawal treaty
as it stands so I think it does raise a
whole set of separate questions which I
think need to be looked at properly and
I do think the government needs to take
a proper uh um reflection of of how the
Windsor framework requires I've heard of
changes to the uh to the bill is drafted
at the moment
on you started a few hairs running there
[Laughter]
yes
with various uh genetic modifications
those hairs
um the the
um nothing to technically uh just a
reminder that that new decade new
approach was very clear on the
commitment to unfettered access for uh
for ni for ni2gb but the sentence about
uh Nolan's inputable part as an integral
part of the UK internal Market is in the
context of the application of the
protocol that's explicit in ndna itself
and so it's all I say I only mention
that because the issues that uh have
been raised by other contributors are
are real and will apply and the question
is is how electively and operationally
uh we can minimize the difficulties that
will arise
that's all I would want to add at this
point uh James I mean I I've got very
little to add to the comments that have
come before so I think the the issue
exactly that issue of the Northern
Ireland business is not benefiting from
changes to UK regulation and yet facing
competition from Goods that are produced
to UK
um standards is a is a real problem I
think the second comes from the question
that we discussed earlier around the
fact that the storm outbreak doesn't
anticipate significant consultation it
operates as a break at the end rather
than as a as a formal role of
consultation during the process of
legislative development
um and I think you know one of the
consequences of that is that you know
insofar as things come up in working
groups or at an official level you know
the EU will take the view that the way
that the UK can solve any problems it's
raising in that context so if you change
the law it'll harm Northern Ireland in
ABC way then the eu's response will be
well you know the the UK is in a
position to fix that by by tagging along
uh and so I think you know it it natural
it will create a natural drag-along uh
effect I think
um
which
I mean it's sort of uh in the nature of
it
you had a question to ask and then
you're going to then then it's
you to ask a question anyway yes thank
you and Lord chair it's just a question
to Anton in relation to the EU Regional
in global in fact I had some amendments
to have to do with article two of the
protocol to do with human rights and
equality and environmental
considerations the minister Lord
callanan kept insisting that there would
be no incompatibility between the
Windsor framework and and EU returned
Lobel so if you have any sort of
background information on that that
would be very useful to the committee
and could I make a suggestion Lord chair
if you could provide us with that that
would be of immense help
can definitely provide that in
brightsync after the session but I would
just make a brief comment I mean there
is a very easy way of dealing with this
problem actually and that is
um
carving out
legislation which is required under the
protocol the amended protocol now
uh to be to be to be Exempted from
provisions of
um of breaking the global to the extent
that those concerns arise because that
would essentially deal with that problem
of course the approach that government
seek was to care about ni specific
legislation from the scope of the bull
but that does not lead that does not
deal with the problem I'm afraid of UK
wide legislation which has applicability
in Northern Ireland and equality
protection is obviously one very good
example of that but
standards for manufacturing products
would be another example those those are
those are not uh those are not dealt
with by ni specific legislation those
are dealt with by uk-wide standards so
there's a whole set of examples I think
which would fall in this camp
and thank you and if I could move on
then to the one the question on
Veterinary medicines and human medicines
and can I just say we're we're running
up against the clock but we'll go on if
it's all right everybody will go on just
till the very latest 10 past we've got a
question from you uh Barons Ritchie and
then Lord Thomas
The Windsor framework already deals with
human Pharma or human medicines so how
would you assess the current situation
and with regard to Veterinary medicines
and what the steps need to be taken to
agree a long-term solution before the
expiry of the grace period at the end of
2025 and I think in the commentary
associated with the Windsor framework
there was indications that they would
hope to reach an agreement and in terms
of a permanent agreement and also in
what is your assessment of the Windsor
framework provisions on the supply of
human medicines to Northern Ireland and
do you think they did sufficiently with
the issues previously raised by industry
in relation to the protocol and many of
those issues were raised by those
involved in the human pharmaceutical
industry to our particular Committee in
our last inquiry so if I start with um
Jess
um I mean in the interest of of brevity
when it comes to Veterinary medicines I
think it's clear that a solution does
need to be found on that and that was uh
as you say the intention of that was
signaled in the agreement I don't I'm
not exactly sure why that wasn't part of
this agreement but I think it's
important that that issue gets resolved
um in terms of the provisions on human
medicines
um I think these acquis this agreement
does go a long way to resolving a lot of
the issues that uh some of the uh
industry have been raising particularly
around being able to produce a single
pack
um in order to sell medicines uh both in
Great Britain and Northern Ireland by
removing the requirement to comply with
the falsified medicines direct if that's
been achieved and I think that's really
helpful uh I think uh allowing the mrha
to regulate for the whole of the UK
again particularly in the issues around
Innovative and novel medicines is a
really positive development and again
addresses some of the concerns of
industry and that coupled with some of
the recent announcements in the budget
as well well around
um regulatory cooperation
um with the EMA and the FDA I think also
uh go further in ensuring that we're
unlikely to end up in a situation where
certain medicines aren't accessible in
Northern Ireland
um so that seems to me to be to be very
positive it doesn't go quite as far as
the UK might have liked um in the
command paper in terms of removing
medicines entirely from the protocol but
one of the other things I've heard very
clearly from industry and particularly
in the medicines industry where
um pharmaceutical companies are often
having to make take regulatory decisions
for several years in the future uh is
that actually what's really important to
them is certainty and hopefully this has
gone a long way in providing that thank
you Anton I've just added that actually
medicines is one example where we see a
genuine example of dual regulatory
regime now the northern Irish businesses
will be able to benefit from
authorizations by both the European
medicines agency but also mhra uh which
is domestic regulator so I do think this
is a very good arrangement actually for
Northern Irish businesses and it does
open up possibilities and it does
introduce a degree of regulator
competition which can be a good thing
because it can encourage Regulators to
think differently and more creatively
about
approaching the same regulator
objectives but in a slightly different
way
in relation to Veterinary medicines I
think this is still an outstanding
question essentially because it is dealt
with by a temporary exemption that has
been passed by European Parliament but
it does not provide a permanent solution
yet so I'm hoping that the Joint
Committee at some point would look at
this issue again and address it by
essentially an extension or turning into
it into permanent solution
James I have nothing to add to Anton's
comments thank you and Andrew
likewise in the interest of time nothing
to add thank you thank you Lord chair
okay thank you very much
there were two competing views about the
role of the European Court
the EU in the briefing that I referred
to Sid there's no change to the role of
the court of justice of the European
Union the court of justice Remains the
sole and ultimate Arbiter of EU law
on the other hand the UK government says
that the storm and break and the UK's
veto in The Joint Committee can only be
challenged through independent
arbitration mechanisms not the ecj
the remaining removing the ultimate
authority of the ecga in areas in which
it would affect day-to-day lives and
there are other statements made by the
British government that we've got rid of
the ECG I understood the arbitration
Arrangements which are referred to
do do of course contain the possibility
of an arbitrator seeking the views of
the ecj on a point of European law
that's how it's supposed to work isn't
it and I've also myself suggested that
if at least for face saving you put that
any point of of English or UK law should
be referred to the to the Supreme Court
of this country but never mind about
that what do you think about the
arbitration
situation and the role of the ecj James
so
the eu's position is closer to the truth
I think uh so that there is no change uh
substantively to the role of the ecj
um except in the context of the storm on
break so the storm up break does and
that the the dispute of rising under the
storm won't break which would be whether
or not the UK was entitled to exercise
it so you know the various procedural
requirements we've talked about I know
together with the substantive
requirements of significant effect and
all of that that dispute is raised
before the
um arbitral uh Tribune or the bilateral
arbitration mechanism in the withdrawal
agreement rather than directly to uh to
the ecga
whereas under the withdrawal agreement
failure to can Implement a rule would
have been you know treated as if it were
a member State failure and that would
have gone straight to the ECG so that is
a change
um but other than that there is no
change to the role of the ecj uh in in
my view
um the second point is that insofar as
you were going to have any mechanism
based on EU law
the questions of EU law have to go to
the ecj because of the the decisions of
the ecj itself right in mayor and in
other judgments the ecga has been very
clear that it is the only Court that's
confident to interpret EU law so if you
have EU law in your agreement you have
the ecj in your agreement pretty much to
the same extent and the only question
then is the procedural route by which
you reach the ecj
effectively the the arbitration
procedure has been placed in between in
respect to the storm and break the storm
and break has been placed in between the
installment breaking in which only
applies in the circumstances we've
discussed earlier yeah so that's a new
law where the substantive Provisions you
know allowing its application apply
otherwise the ECGs position is under the
protocol is unchanged
right
yes
I brutally intrigued with Jameson's
assessment that there has been no
material change to article 12 which is
essentially granting the European code
of justice jurisdiction our provisions
of the law that applied to Northern
Ireland
it also means that UK codes which are
dealing with any domestic disputes
relating to potential application of the
law
would still be empowered to and in some
cases under obligations to seek
preliminary reference to the European
code of justice with respect to those
those issues which I think is really
important again in the context of
retained illogial which does contain
some Provisions for giving UK codes more
discretion to decide how they want to
approach questions which had been
previously dealt by the European court
of justice so I can see a potential for
some inconsistency here
what I would say is
um
that from a business point of view if if
you're a business in Northern Ireland
which would feel that their rights have
been infringed essentially by another
company within the EU and would seek a
remedy it is in the interest of that
business to ensure that they receive the
same remedy as any other European
business facing a similar issue and that
is essentially ensured by way of
um ultimately asking the European court
of justice for its verdict so I think
from a business point of view it does
provide a degree of certainty and
stability
uh and it's not necessarily a bad thing
but I do appreciate that uh there has
been no change to that provision the
Northern Ireland business would want to
go to the European Court to resolve an
issue which involved for example the
application of of certain regulations is
that right I mean it's a it's a benefit
to business and Northern Ireland is it I
think it's a benefits to ensure that
businesses that are competing in the
same Market
um have access to the same remedies at
the end of the day if there was a
concern for the business
and that's ultimately where you can get
the final recourse is for the European
court of justice so I can see I can see
that so that's sober lining of this
arrangement
on the other hand if the the contract a
contract had been agreed to be ruled by
UK law then of course they'd use the UK
courts to resolve disputes
that's right about as if if that dispute
was about application of
um EU law under the amended protocol UK
domesticon would still have to ask uh
could could it could end up in a
scenario that the EK code might have to
ask the European court of justice for
its opinion on the points of
interpretation through the preliminary
reference procedure which which does
exist
enough
okay
grateful thank you
well thank you very much all of you
um that's been extremely helpful and
it's got our new inquiry up to an
extremely good start and
um there are a lot of quite
tricky and important issues to consider
and we started well so thank you very
much indeed for the evidence that you've
given us we are extremely grateful and I
declare this formal part of the meeting
closed